This makeGreyScale function is fairly similar to what we did before.
After retrieving the data from the imageData object, we call makePixelGrayScale
on it, and then we store that information back into imageData.
I used a slightly more optimized formula to calculate the grayscale
of the pixel.
It takes 30% of the red value, 59% of the green value and 11% of the blue value.
So when we go over here and
refresh our page, we'll see that it's gone to a grayscale.
There's some interesting science that explains how and
why we perceive color the way we do.
See the instructor's notes for links if you'd like to learn more about it and
also for a link to the image that we used in this example.